Next time you find yourself doing a frantic little dance in front of a smart door.
Oh, yeah, waving your arms around.
Right, waving your arms, stepping forward, stepping back, just trying to trigger a sensor that is completely invisible. You aren't just confused, you know. You are experiencing the fundamental flaw of modern technology design.
Yeah, you're basically doing a universal human pantomime to beg a machine to acknowledge your existence.
Exactly. And welcome to today's Deep Dive. We're looking at Justine Cassell's seminal paper, Embodied Conversational Agents. And the mission today for you, the listener, is to figure out why the tech industry's obsession with making computers just,
like, disappear is actually a massive mistake.
Right, because for decades, the holy grail for engineers has been ubiquitous computing. Make it invisible.
Like electricity.
Exactly, like electricity. Just embed the intelligence seamlessly into the walls and the furniture so you never have to look at a machine again. But giving computers a physical body to communicate with you isn't a step backwards. It's actually the ultimate interface.
Okay, let's unpack this. Because I'm sure a lot of people are thinking, well, invisible interfaces are cleaner.
Yeah, they definitely look cleaner.
Yeah, they remove physical clutter.
Yeah.
If the room simply knows I want the lights on or the door open, adding an avatar or a visible camera seems like a regression. Why force humans to look at the machine's brain when ambient intelligence just handles the task?
What's fascinating here is the concept of located intelligence. Humans evolved to interact with entities in a localized space.
You don't just exist in a vacuum.
Right. When you interact with a person or a dog or even a basic mechanical liver, you know exactly where to direct your attention.
You know where the intelligence is originating from.
Exactly. When you strip that away and the intelligence is just everywhere, it feels like it's nowhere. You don't make the process easier. You actually force the human to guess.
Which is unnerving to the brain. And it brings up that amazing Harry Potter quote from the paper.
Oh, I love that one.
Yeah, Arthur Weasley says, never trust anything that can think for itself if you can't see where it keeps its brain.
It captures the psychological friction perfectly. We need to locate the intelligence to trust it, to model its limitations, and to collaborate with it.
And the most sophisticated example of located intelligence we have is our own physical body.
Precisely.
So if we do need a visible body to interact with, we really have to understand how human bodies actually communicate. Because it's not just talking.
Not at all. We tend to think of conversation like reading a text transcript, just words.
Yeah.
But Cassell breaks down human communication into two distinct streams happening simultaneously.
OK, break those down for me.
So you have propositional functions and interactional functions. Propositional functions govern the actual content. The meaning.
Like the vocabulary.
Yeah. So the vocabulary and grammar, but also gestures that convey hard data. Like if you hold your hands two feet apart to show the size of a fish you caught. Oh,
right. That's a propositional gesture. It delivers information.
Exactly. Then you have interactional functions. These are the cues that regulate the process of the conversation itself.
Like a quick head nod to show I'm following your story.
Yeah. Or looking up in a way to indicate you're pausing to think of your next sentence. So I shouldn't interrupt you yet.
Right. So it functions a lot like a transportation network. Propositional is the cargo you're delivering in a truck. It's the actual goods.
I like that.
And interactional is the traffic control system. The turn signals, the brake lights, making sure the cargo actually gets there safely without a crash.
That is a perfect analogy, because if you just dump the cargo onto the road without any signals, you get a conversational pileup, people talking over each other. Which
happens all the time on video calls.
Oh, exactly. Because those interactional cues are either delayed or missing entirely.
So there's a brilliant real-world observation in the paper about this. A woman describing the layout of a house to a man.
Yes. She says the house is surrounded by a porch all around, and as she speaks, her hands physically map out that the porch covers three sides.
That's the propositional cargo, giving spatial geometry that English vocabulary struggles with.
Right, saying front, left, and right sides interrupts the flow. A quick sweep of the hands is instant. But right in the middle of that sentence, she briefly shifts her eye gaze toward the man.
She makes eye contact to elicit a quick nod from him.
Yes. And once she gets that nod verifying he understands, she continues, that eye contact is entirely interactional.
Checking the traffic lights.
Exactly. And we do this continuously, completely unconsciously.
Which makes a particular statistic from the text really stand out. Cassell notes that 50% of spontaneous gestures add non-redundant information to a conversation.
That blew my mind. Non-redundant.
Meaning the gestures aren't just decorative flair. They carry critical pieces of the message that the spoken words simply are not carrying.
Right. So if you are only listening to the audio or interacting with a smart speaker in your kitchen, you are literally missing half the data.
Half. This puts a hard artificial ceiling on how effective an invisible interface can ever be. A disembodied voice doesn't have hands to show you things.
And it can't see your spatial mapping in return.
Here's where it gets really interesting, though. How do we actually program a machine to understand this intricate dance?
Overcoming that ceiling requires the FMBT model, often pronounced fembar.
Functions, modalities, behaviors, and timing.
Right. Because traditionally, programming an avatar meant writing brittle, trigger-based rules. If the user says hello, then trigger the waving animation.
Basically, a tape recorder with a graphical face pasted on top.
Yes. But the FMBT model leaps past that by proposing modality-free representation.
Modality-free. What does that actually mean for the computer's brain?
It means the system's internal knowledge, the core concept it wants to express, does not exist initially as a word or a gesture. It exists purely as an abstract, modality-free node.
Like having a craving for a specific food. The craving itself is pure thought. It doesn't have a language yet.
Exactly. Once you have the craving, your brain dynamically decides the best way to express it. You could say, I'm hungry for a burger.
Or point at a menu.
Or mime eating a sandwich if the room is loud. The core concept is the same, but the output modality changes based on context.
Wow. So the system decides, millisecond by millisecond, the absolute best way to output info.
Yes, and if we connect this to the bigger picture, it means behaviors are not functions.
Okay, explain the difference there.
Let's look at a simple head nod. That is a physical behavior, but its function is completely variable.
Right, sometimes it functions as feedback, like I am listening. Sometimes it's a greeting in the hallway.
Or it's used to put emphasis on a specific spoken syllable. The reverse is equally true. If the system's desired function is give feedback, it doesn't have to nod.
It could say, mm, or raise its virtual eyebrows.
Exactly. It figures out the function, checks what channels are available, and dynamically picks a modality.
And processing all this takes a staggering amount of computational power, especially when you factor in the T in FMBT, timing.
Timing is the glue that holds human interaction together.
The system isn't just taking turns speaking. It's operating on microsecond scales. Cassell details this 200-millisecond rule.
It's incredibly precise. If a speaker's voice goes up in intonation, requesting feedback, and the listener nods within a 200 millisecond window.
That translates to, I understand, keep going.
Right. But if that exact same head nod is delayed by just half a second... And
meaning completely inverts.
Yes. A late nod signifies confusion or hesitation. The speaker will unconsciously read that, stop their sentence, and usually backtrack to clarify.
Wait, really? Just half a second completely changes the conversation.
It really does. So an embodied agent has to ingest video feeds, parse audio, generate a modality-free concept, map it to a physical output, and render it on a screen.
Within a quarter of a second.
Yes, on the fly.
So what does this look like when it's actually built?
This brings us to REA. REA, the virtual real estate agent built by Cassell and her team at MIT.
She's a fascinating proof of concept. She appears on a life-size projection screen, right?
Yeah, giving her a localized physical presence in the room. And she uses an array of cameras to actively track you standing in front of her.
So she's not just listening.
No, she's monitoring the position of your hands, the tilt of your head, everything.
How does she map multimodal cues with the FMBT model?
Say her language engine decides to tell you a virtual house is five minutes from the train station. Because she uses modality-free representation, she splits that data across two channels dynamically.
She verbalizes the words, it's five minutes to the station.
Right, but simultaneously she extends her index and middle fingers pointing downward and wiggles them back and forth.
A walking gesture.
Exactly. The speech says five minutes, but the gesture adds non-redundant propositional cargo. It specifies a five-minute walk, not a drive.
She didn't have to say on foot. Her body just carried the extra data seamlessly.
And if she describes a room as luminous, the system might have her make an expansive sunrising gesture with both arms.
Complementary gestures, emphasizing the scale of the light without extra adjectives. What about interactional cues? What if I interrupt her?
This is the best part. If she's describing a beautiful master bathroom and you suddenly bring your hands up into the space between you or you inhale sharply...
She immediately halts.
Yes. She yields the floor at the nearest sentence boundary because her cameras recognize you are making a physical bid for the turn.
She understands the protocol of interruption.
She isn't waiting for a pause in your audio file. She's analyzing your posture to anticipate your desire to speak.
which creates the illusion of true presence. And contrasting REA with the spectacular failures of early virtual assistants really solidifies why this matters.
We have to talk about the dreaded paperclip.
Microsoft's Clippy. People despised it.
Universally hated. But the FMBT model provides the exact forensic explanation for why.
They just slapped a cartoon body onto standard event listening software.
Exactly. Clippy did not understand conversational protocols. It would pop up and interrupt you in an incredibly socially inappropriate manner while you were actively typing.
And it's crucial to understand that interruption itself isn't the problem. Humans interrupt each other constantly.
But human interruption is motivated by the interactional state of the conversation. You look for eye contact. You wait for a lull.
Clippy operated on software state changes, not conversational state
changes. Right. It saw document opened or user typing deer and just executed a behavior. It had no cameras to see if you were deep in thought.
When you ignored it, it would tap the screen or look around. It's the equivalent of someone staring at their watch and sighing loudly while you're intensely focused.
Totally obnoxious. In the early 2000s, virtual newscaster and Innova suffered a similar fate.
Oh, right. The creators advertised her full personality. She would sway, wink, sneer while reading the news.
But the movement was entirely puppetry. Hand-scripted animation loosely tied to text strings.
She didn't use her body to convey propositional content. Like she wasn't mapping out financial charts with her hands.
No. And she completely ignored interactional cues from the viewer. She didn't pause to check if you understood.
It was the illusion of a body without the intelligence of conversation. Anthropomorphism, just to look cute.
They treated the physical body as an aesthetic decoration instead of the interface itself.
So what does this all mean for you, the listener? True, intelligent interfaces aren't just about giving a computer a human face.
It's about embedding the deep, unspoken rules of human social interaction into the system.
Right. Making the technology work with our natural instincts rather than fighting them.
And this raises an important question to leave you with. By spending all this time, all this massive engineering power trying to teach computers how to talk with their bodies, are we actually just holding up a mirror to ourselves?
Oh, wow.
Think about it. We treat conversation as a casual thing. You grab a coffee, you chat. But when you look at the math required to replicate a simple, hmm, or a 200 millisecond gaze shift.
You realize how shockingly complex and beautiful human behaviors really are.
We do all of this completely unconsciously.
We really do. Next time you have a simple chat, pay attention to your hands. Watch how you use space to describe an idea.
Pay attention to exactly when you break eye contact to think.
You aren't just chatting. You are running a highly advanced, flawlessly synchronized, real-time operating system.
You really are. And the invisible interfaces we rely on today still have a tremendous amount to learn from the human body.
Absolutely. So let me figure it out. Keep looking for the intelligence in the room.